-Will Farrell, everybody!
Come on!
Thank you for being here!
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you for
coming back to the show
and enjoy yourself, guys.
Yeah, thanks.
The -- The -- Will.
-Jimmy, aren't you just lost
in the holiday magic?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, I am.
Was this --
Was this what you're
bringing us here?
What is this you brought?
-Well, Jimmy, you know I have
a passion for miniatures
because I'm a bit of
a control freak.
-Okay. Yeah.
-So every January
I begin construction
of my perfect Christmas village.
-Oh.
-And since the holidays
are almost here,
I thought it would be
fun to bring it here
and share it with all of you.
-Oh, my God. This is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, this --
-Yeah.
-It's really impressive.
What --
-I haven't even shown you
the best part yet.
Look.
[ Switch clicks ]
-Wow! Look at that!
-Ohh.
-Wow, that's very good.
-Would you like for me
to give you a tour?
-I would love to
see a tour of this.
-Oh, oh, okay.
If you do the honor
of sprinkling a little
Christmas snow...
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
...over the village.
-Over the village, sure.
-And fellas, can I get some
music that says
"Holiday magic?"
Oh, thank you. Okay.
Welcome to my perfect
Christmas village.
-Wow.
-The season starts downtown
with our village gazebo.
-Oh!
And look here,
a friendly snowball fight.
-[ Laughs ]
Incredible detail.
Who's this guy over here?
-Oh! That's Michael
the Popcorn Man.
-Oh.
And who is she?
-Oh, that's Francine.
She's the town heartbreaker.
[ Laughter ]
But it's not just the people
that make a Christmas village
perfect...
-Uh-huh.
-...look at these
darling shops here.
-Uh-huh. Yeah. Yeah.
I see you have
a post office there.
-Yeah.
-You have a hardware store.
-And don't forget to buy
all your Christmas cigars
at the cigar shop.
Mmm.
Is there anything that says
holiday cheer
like the smell of
a Christmas cigar?
[ Light laughter ]
-I guess, I guess.
Sure, I guess.
I never, uh...
-You guess?
I know.
-Oh, okay, you do?
-Yeah.
You know?
Crap, I've never heard of that.
What is this factory over here?
This is a factory?
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah?
They make toys there?
Or candy canes or something?
-No. Nobody knows
what goes on there.
[ Laughter ]
Not even me.
-What's this over here?
-Oh! That's the
Ross Dress For Less.
[ Laughter ]
And, uh, and that's
where the towns people
shop when they want dresses.
-Uh-huh.
-But for less.
-Yeah, I gotcha.
-Uh, over here we have people
getting their photos with Santa.
But you better be good,
or no Christmas cigars for you.
[ Laughter ]
And here's our
reindeer petting zoo.
-Oh, that's got --
Oh, it looks like there's some
are there some wolves
in there with the reindeer?
-Uh-huh.
Well, Santa's busy
with other things,
so the wolves are there
to keep the reindeer in check.
-Uh, it looks like some wolves
have actually escaped
and are walking around town.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, they vote, so they've
earned their right to be there.
-The wolves --
The wolves vote?
-The wolves run the town, Jimmy.
They run it all.
So you better not say
anything bad about them.
[ Panting, heaving ]
Hey, [ Whimpering ]
it's not almost midnight, is it?
[ Panting ]
[ Laughter ]
-It -- It --
It i-- It i--
It i-- It is.
-Oh, no.
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh. Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
Not on the full moon!
Not now!
Ahh!
It burns!
-Oh, oh, oh.
What -- What -- Will!
What's going on?
-I'm turning into a werewolf.
[ Grunting, gurgling ]
And I told a fib.
That's not the original
Michael the Popcorn Man.
I ate the real Michael.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
-I woke up the next morning
in the gazebo... naked.
I couldn't remember anything,
but I could taste popcorn man.
You have to take me
to the factory!
Take me to the factory and
handcuff me to the radiator
for your own safety!
[ Grunting, gurgling continues ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wait, wait, wait!
Is that all I can --
-[ Grumbling, growling ]
-Is that
Is that all I can do?
-It's a long process.
-Oh, my God.
-This is terrible.
What can I do?!
-The village needs blood!
Needs new, fresh blood!
-What?
-Oh, I have an idea!
I have an idea!
I have a tiny figurine of me.
-Oh.
-Maybe if I put him in
your Christmas village,
that could be good?
-It's the only way!
[ Breathing heavily ]
-Look at there.
-Jimmy --
[ Applause ]
Jimmy, I told another fib.
-What?
-I wasn't really
turning into a werewolf.
[ Laughter ]
-I just needed to see
if you had Christmas heart.
And I needed to know if you
could save my village,
and you did it!
You saved Christmas!
Holiday cigar?
-Wow! Thanks, buddy!
-Yeah?
Will Farrell, everybody.
More with Will after the break.
Come on back!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my -- What?
[ Cheers and applause ]